if you don't know jenny thomas i mean
this is clarence thomas's wife now we
know there she is
uh
yeah
that picture i don't know that picture
comes from that day but she was at the
january sixth riot yeah she participated
in what was basically urging on a coup
she participated in something that was
all about
stopping the vice president of the
united states
from certifying a vote which they knew
was a legitimate vote that's who is
now she always says
clarence and i
we don't really talk about politics at
home we don't i can see that that
there's silence at the dinner table they
are married
[Applause]
and now we have some of her texts where
she was urging on the washington post
got a hold of her text she's urging on
trump's chief of staff after november
after the votes have been counted to
overturn this election based on crazy q
arm theories
is there anything to be done about this
because clarence thomas plainly he was
the lone guy to the lone dissenting vote
when this when the court ruled that the
january 6 committee yes could get
trump's papers that were related to that
this is uh
i'd like to live here i think i think
it's very disturbing because one of the
things one of the big qualities you need
to have with the supreme court justice
is independence and to be able to look
at the facts and make a decision based
on the facts and when you're being
influenced by the person that's sitting
next to you and they might say they
don't talk i don't buy that or they
wouldn't be well maybe they would still
be married but the truth is is that you
visit with your spouse that's a secret
it's a communication secret to a long
marriage but i'm telling you it puts his
independence in question
and he should he should be recusing
himself from any of these these issues
[Applause]
the woman has been the woman has been a
crazy
crazy right-wing activist for the entire
time that her husband has been on the
supreme court more crazy in more recent
years as this happened with the party in
general you read the text messages bill
it's like who's your nuttiest
most brain diseased
well trump maga following relative the
one who's been at brain alley by
syphilis or whatever
and they've completely gone around the
bend and they do all their posting
on facebook that's what her text
messages sound like she's writing about
how the biden crime family and reporters
should be sent to military tribunals at
gitmo because of what because of the
fact they were saying that the election
was legitimate after the election in
addition to urging the chief of staff to
be like a political consultant to the
chief of staff it is possible that
clarence thomas didn't know that
although they have both called
themselves each other's best friends on
many occasions in public but is this an
issue not just for craziness it's an
issue of corruption it's like there is a
there's a federal the supreme court has
no ethical guidelines on it whatsoever
for judges there's no code of ethics on
the supreme court but the rest of
federal judges and that includes them in
some sense uh are said that you can't
rule in a case in which your spouse or
family members can can benefit in some
way this was a case where she as a
member of a right-wing cabal that wants
to overthrow the election would benefit
potentially from uh
not having trump's uh communications
come forward and also she would
personally benefit from not having those
communications come forward he was
conflicted out of this case
did he ever admit that his wife went to
the stop to steal rally no did he admit
that there was any possible conflict of
interest no he should not only be barred
from ruling on any case related to the
january 6th issue i think there's a
pretty good case he should be censured
in some other way justice roberts needs
to get serious about this
because
he talks all the time about the fact and
he's right that the court the supreme
courts standing in american life now is
worse than it's been any time in our
lifetime americans do think the court
has been politicized they think it's not
credible this is the kind of that
makes people think that and they're
right to think that in this case you got
to do something about it well i don't
know i don't know yeah i don't know we
can but
this
should just so that people don't think
you're exaggerating or i'm exaggerating
about this let me read
the thing you were alluding to before
yeah about gitmo please she actually
thought that was actually happening it
wasn't a proposal she was
looking at these q and on conspiracy
theory the q and on believes that trump
put water marks on the ballots
so he could tell when fraud was
happening so biden cri this is ginny's
this is ginny's text biden crime family
and ballot fraud co-conspirators
are being arrested and detained for
ballot fraud right now
and over the coming days we'll be living
in barges off of gitmo
to face military tribunals for sedition
she also said release the kraken this is
she's talking to his chief of staff
i think she's smoking the kraken
release
[Applause]
release the kraken and save us from the
left taking america down and then at one
point she also says many of us can't
continue the gop charade i thought that
was interesting the gop charade in other
words republicans are not nearly
conservative enough not that it's
conservative to want to take over the
country it's cool she's so crazy that
even house rats thinks she's crazy
right
okay
yeah i don't know i don't know what to
do i don't have a solution
you